ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first one hey David with
everything going on with coronavirus can
the United States federal government
forcibly quarantine people and not allow
them to leave their homes as usual this
is a question that has a number of
different answers part of it because we
have state and local government it's
also a question that I would prefer we
not actually test the limits of let's
not make it necessary to find out if the
federal government can forcibly require
people to stay in their homes I think
we're all much better off going along
with what it is that we are doing to try
to stop the spread of coronavirus I know
that it sucks I want to be going to
places I want to be going to cafes I
want to be hanging out with people I get
it okay but we've all got to do our part
time to put up the pull-up your big-boy
pants and do your part but now let's
explore it realistically sort of
lockdowns would be happening at a state
level rather than the federal government
level more than likely again we can talk
about these scenarios where martial law
is declared and the the government sends
the military but more realistically this
would be happening at the state level so
we actually have an example here in
Massachusetts from the Boston Marathon
bombing years ago and the Scott Sillman
silly man who is emeritus director of
the center on law and national security
at Duke Law School says lockdowns really
are voluntary the governor says they
want people to shelter in place and
shelter in place can be used in a
pandemic it can be used if there's
dangerous people on the loose as was the
case with the Boston Marathon bombing
and you're essentially saying stay where
you are either to not expose yourself to
a violent criminal who's out on the
street to not expose yourself or others
to a virus or disease of some kind
shelter in place that is different than
a state of emergency which then has more
sort of financial implications in terms
of states being able to mobilize and
accept certain resources from the
federal government and in either case
you can try to institute penalties of
fines or prison for people who violate
some of these
Cree's more likely they take place with
violations of curfews and things
associated with states of emergency
then with requests to shelter in place
so again it really depends on in which
state this happens as we already know
there's a huge partisan divide with
coronavirus Republicans are far less
worried about it Republicans are far
less likely to be modifying their
behavior as a result Republicans three
times more likely to be hanging out in
bars and restaurants and ignoring all of
the recommendations from the CDC you
would I would imagine also see different
states handle this differently and as a
result you you would likely start to see
some trends in terms of states that are
doing better and worse in terms of the
virus
my recommendation is let's not make it
necessary to test the legal limits of
recommendations that people stay home
now from a practical perspective if you
close down schools ban gatherings of
more than 25 people close down bars and
restaurants other than for takeout and
delivery if banks closed a lot of public
facing businesses closed and you shut
down public transportation which can be
done more relevant in cities you are
going to get a lot of people who just
aren't going to go anywhere because
where the hell are they going to go and
that's also becoming a reality certainly
certainly here in Massachusetts but
let's let's cooperate let's do the right
thing let's understand that even if we
think when we go out we're not doing
anything imagine that when you go out
you were putting an 80 year old or a kid
who's immunocompromised in danger I
don't want to be doing that I don't want
to participate in that so I'm limiting
what I'm doing